let's go next to the nine one six area
code caller from nine one six who's this
where you calling from
hey David this is Tony
I'm calling from California I just kind
of wanted to talk about what you think
about the market and this giant drop
that we had today and whether it's an
indication of a more severe drop like we
had back in what was at 2007-2008 yeah
or if this is just more of a more minor
correction nobody knows I mean listen
here's the thing to the extent that
there have always been downturns
historically we knew that the longer the
run up in the stock market went the
closer we were to a correction but like
I'm literally not saying anything unique
there other than as time passes you are
closer to the next correction whenever
it is that's a very unremarkable
statement over the last couple of years
it has become increasingly apparent that
stock market valuations have been
significantly over getting ahead of the
value of a lot of these companies based
on earnings and based on assets so that
is what we might call froth in the stock
markets or to quote alan greenspan
irrational exuberance I don't know call
it whatever you want so we've basically
now lost all of the gains of 2018 and
most of the markets are now just
slightly down from where they started
2018 so 2018 now is gone there's been no
gains in 2018
of course dividends can sort of outdo
that if you're earning two three percent
dividends then that's basically what
you've earned in 2018 because stock
prices are basically even the next
question is what you are asking which is
is this the bottom of now starting to
recover or is this just the beginning of
a larger correction which could be 15
percent it could be 20 percent I have no
idea anyone who pretends to know is just
guessing all I can tell you is my
personal story which
is when I log in and look at my mutual
fund account it's really depressing the
last couple of months and I look at it
and I'm just kind of like oh oh where'd
the money go this this doesn't seem good
and I tell you what it is that's going
to happen next
I guess my next question is you know
last year probably around July my family
we were looking to buy a house but the
prices of houses here in California
especially but particularly in this
market are so incredibly high that and
it was so competitive as well that we
were getting outbid like we would go in
at three hundred and seventy five
thousand on their house and someone from
the Bay Area would come in at 4:15 and
there's just no way I must be completely
settled on a house so we decided to not
buy a house at all when do you think it
would be a smart time to even make that
kind of a leap or a jump into a house
well listen I am going to tell you I am
NOT going to give you financial advice
because that's not what I do on the
program but here here's what I will say
about housing markets there are starting
to be signs of significant slowdown
nationally in the housing market and
thus if over the next two to four years
prices decline those could be moments to
get in but here's the thing about real
estate real estate markets are very
compartmentalized so you will likely see
that the hot markets like New York
knock on wood Boston remains one for my
sake and some of those others some of
those hot markets that are places people
are continuing to to move to and that
money is coming in - even if nationally
stopped home prices decline you may not
see significant declines or any declines
in those hot markets because the markets
are very compartmentalized so the answer
is you're just going to have to wait and
see when if and when there is a price
level that works for you perfect thank
you so much all right thanks so much
really appreciate the call shortened
calls because of the Thanksgiving
holiday
so I am out of time apologies to the 32
people I really do apologize 32 people
who are holding but I am out of time
more calls next week I promise
today's program sponsored in part by
blinkers comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting
you could listen to ten books in an
afternoon I know that many in our
audience want to expand their horizons
and learn more about all sorts of
different topics but we're mostly
limited by time to some degree I know
I'm not able to read all of the books
that I want simply because I've got
other stuff going on and that's why
blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand I think you are
going to like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to be li NK is t.com slash PA que ma
n